When I stand up and give a talk, I don't want people to see that talk and think, you know, wow, that was cool, but I could not approach that. What I want people to take away is like, that was cool. I'm going to go try that in my code base. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 217 recorded on December 16th 2024. My name is Connor today with my co host Ben we chat about different styles of talks, we diagnose a bug and more. more a question that occurred to me earlier is there a way uh you mentioned that a lot of things a lot of times in your videos you show building up a function and then converting it to tacit form i assume there's an automatic way to convert it to tacit form that's because that exists in other functional languages i'm pretty sure yes i don't know if it exists for BQN. I definitely know that not only does it exist for J, but there is it actually built in what they call a foreign function in J that goes from explicit to tacit.
当我站起来做演讲时，我不希望人们看完后觉得：“哇，那很酷，但我根本学不来。”我希望人们带走的是：“那很酷，我要去我的代码库里试一试。”欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 217 期，录制于 2024 年 12 月 16 日。我是 Connor，今天我和联合主持人 Ben 将聊聊不同风格的演讲、诊断一个 Bug 等等。之前我有个疑问，你提到在视频中经常展示如何构建一个函数，然后将其转换为隐式（tacit）形式。我假设有一种自动转换到隐式形式的方法，因为其他函数式语言中存在这种功能，我非常确定。是的，我不确定 BQN 是否有。但我肯定知道 J 语言不仅有，而且内置了所谓的“外部函数”（foreign function），可以将显式形式转换为隐式形式。
I know Haskell has pointfree.io that goes from explicit to tacit as well. I would imagine there's a bqn one out there i don't actually know because by the time i started learning bqn i was already enough of like a tacit uh expert to like i don't need ever to go to those tools in fact like right that's one of my biggest worries and is that you know i've the evolution of whatever my algorithmic combinatory path is that like i love the combinator stuff so much is that like i've the evolution of whatever my algorithmic combinatory path is that like i love the combinator stuff so much is that like i've i've become that teacher that has lost all sense of like how complicated a thing is because they swim in the topic and it's been so long since they they
我知道 Haskell 有 pointfree.io，也可以将显式转换为隐式。我想 BQN 应该也有类似的工具，但我其实不知道，因为当我开始学习 BQN 时，我已经是一个隐式编程的专家了，不需要用到那些工具。事实上，这正是我最大的担忧之一：随着我在算法组合路径上的演进，我太喜欢组合子（combinator）那一套了，以至于我变成了一个老师，完全失去了对“事物有多复杂”的感知，因为我沉浸在这个主题中太久了，太久没有……
struggled with forks and the basic stuff that like uh i'm harming i'm harming the reputation of array languages by showing this cool trickery stuff that is not practical and i like i i've heard folks that say you know we actually need to focus more on the practical array languages like use of array language is not the highfalutin right um combinatory stuff well you can still show the shining beacon on the hill, right? You can still show that, you know, and this that talk and think you know wow that was cool but i could not approach that yeah uh what i want people to take away is like that was cool i'm gonna go try that in my code base yes you want you want there to be takeaways for folks and uh which is why i some of your talks are just you know they're
为分叉（forks）和基础知识而挣扎了。我担心通过展示这些不切实际的炫酷技巧，反而损害了数组语言的声誉。我听到有人说，我们确实需要更多地关注实用的数组语言，而不是那些高深莫测的组合子内容。嗯，你仍然可以展示山顶上闪耀的灯塔，对吧？你仍然可以展示它，即使人们看完觉得“哇，那很酷，但我学不来”。是的，我希望人们带走的是“那很酷，我要去我的代码库里试一试”。是的，你希望人们能有所收获，这就是为什么你的一些演讲……
in my all top i mean i always mention the uh i have sometimes like i don't always hit that mark sometimes i give talks and they are kind of out there sometimes and sometimes that's a good thing it depends on the crowd right like when jason and I did Constexpr all the things at C++ now, that was a great example of a talk which was like here's exploring what's possible. No one in their right mind would
在我所有的演讲中，我总是提到……有时我并没有达到那个目标，有时我的演讲确实有点“出格”，但有时这也是件好事，这取决于听众，对吧？比如当 Jason 和我在 C++ Now 大会上做“Constexpr all the things”演讲时，那是一个很好的例子，展示了什么是可能的。没有一个神志正常的人会……
write what we did that way or really use it in production. But for that crowd, it was like lighting a fire under the standardizing constexpr yeah and i i was i was gonna say before like i always mention the easy to use hard to misuse but then right when you said oh some of my talks are out there it's is it funny that i mentioned that talk all the time it's the talk that hit the hardest for me where i was on my learning path which is why right i i think it's
像我们那样写代码，或者真的在生产环境中使用它。但对于那群听众来说，这就像是在点燃标准化 constexpr 的火种。是的，我本来想说，我总是提到“易于使用，难以误用”，但当你提到你的一些演讲很“出格”时，很有趣的是，我总是提到那个演讲，因为它对我学习路径的影响最深，这就是为什么我认为……
it's okay to give talks at different levels because depending on where everyone is on their learning journey journey like they're gonna watch that talk and be like ah this isn't really anything new under the sun and it's like well okay it's because you learned that stuff already but like for where i was it was like mind exploding yeah i probably at some point not anytime soon we'll have to rein it in on uh on the talks that i give these days even the folks that know the material sometimes um what people say a lot to me these days is like thanks for getting up there and saying that because i've been arguing this to my boss or my colleagues or whatever. And now I can have some backup. I pointed something.
在不同层面进行演讲是可以的，因为取决于每个人在学习旅程中所处的位置，他们看那个演讲时可能会觉得“这没什么新鲜的”，那是因为你已经学过那些东西了。但对于当时的我来说，那简直是醍醐灌顶。是的，我可能在某个时候——虽然不是很快——需要收敛一下我现在的演讲内容。即使是那些了解这些材料的人，人们现在经常对我说的是：“谢谢你站出来说这些，因为我一直在和我的老板或同事争论这些，现在我终于有支持的论据了。”我指出了某点。
Yeah. Yeah. Now I'm in research. So I don't really have to. I write my own code and not many folks look at it. They look at what it does. Right. So I haven't had to have many of those arguments.
是的。现在我在做研究，所以我真的不需要那样做。我写自己的代码，没多少人看，他们只看结果。所以，我不需要进行太多那样的争论。
But definitely I've been on teams before where I'll reference, oh, Kotlin something or Haskell something. And they'll be like, what are you talking about? And I'm like, I'm saying I'm not making this stuff up. Like other languages, this is like a pattern. And then it's like, Ben gives a talk and it's like, okay, now Ben, now there's someone in the C++ world other than me that's saying the same stuff. Right, right. And it's funny because people in the, you know, people in the functional world who,
但我以前确实在一些团队里，我会引用“Kotlin 的某某”或“Haskell 的某某”，他们会问：“你在说什么？”我会说：“我不是在编造这些，在其他语言中，这是一种模式。”然后当 Ben 做演讲时，就像是：“好吧，现在在 C++ 世界里，除了我之外，还有人在说同样的事情。”没错，没错。有趣的是，在函数式编程世界里的人……
some of the stuff I presented in C c++ they've been doing it for years and they look at the talk and they're like oh yeah yeah that's nothing special oh finally c++ is getting this yeah you know yeah there's some memes online of whatever lambda comes to insert language and then everyone's going around it's like you know half a century ago lisp, you know, half a century ago. Lisp, you know, already had it. But hey, it's better late than never, folks. Better late than never. Talking of, let's wrap up. I mentioned to you earlier that you had a bug in one of your solutions to Advent of Code.
我在 C++ 中展示的一些东西，他们已经做了很多年了。他们看我的演讲时会说：“哦，是的，那没什么特别的，哦，终于 C++ 也有这个了。”网上有一些关于“Lambda 引入某语言”的梗，然后每个人都在传，就像是“半个世纪前 Lisp 就有了”。但嘿，迟到总比不到好，伙计们。迟到总比不到好。说到这个，我们总结一下吧。我之前提到你在 Advent of Code 的一个解决方案里有个 Bug。
Talking about going full circle. I believe day seven. Now, when you solved day seven, actually, you showed building up part one. But then the code you showed, you had a reworking for part two. And then you solved both part one and part two with the reworking, which happened to be correct. But I think in your part one work, you had a bug. And the bug was in the evaluation. So day seven was the thing that put the plus and the multiply combinations in between the expression, right?
说到兜兜转转，我相信是第七天。当你解决第七天的问题时，你展示了第一部分的构建过程。但你展示的代码中，你对第二部分进行了重构。然后你用重构后的代码解决了第一部分和第二部分，结果是正确的。但我认为在第一部分的工作中，你有一个 Bug。这个 Bug 在求值过程中。所以第七天的问题是在表达式之间放置加号和乘号的组合，对吧？
I was watching that video, and there was a point where you went from showing the lists, showing the strings to evaluate, and then you changed to showing the evaluation there's a point in the video where it flips over and that had me scratching my head because i'm like that string does not evaluate to that number i think and i think there was a bug therefore like i think bqn is doing does it do right to left evaluation oh yes i think that and i think that's the bug because you have to do left to right evaluation in that problem without operator precedence it's very strict and that is not the same you get different answers doing right to left interesting uh well let's here i'll quickly
我在看那个视频，有一个点你从展示列表、展示要计算的字符串，切换到展示求值过程。视频中有一个翻转的点，这让我很困惑，因为我想：“那个字符串计算出来的结果不是那个数字。”我认为那里有一个 Bug。我认为 BQN 是从右向左求值的吗？哦，是的，我认为这就是 Bug，因为在这个问题中你必须从左向右求值，没有运算符优先级，非常严格。这不一样，从右向左求值会得到不同的答案。有趣，好吧，让我快速……
just so that we can both get the reveal, share my screen for a couple more seconds. So, I can just do this. Right, okay. I have both solutions still in my code. Value is the one that builds up a string. And value two is the one that has a list of actual operations. Mm-hmm. And value two, if I'm looking at this, what is it doing with okay this is a block so
为了让我们都能看到结果，我再共享几秒钟屏幕。我可以这样做。好的，我的代码里还有两个解决方案。Value 是构建字符串的那个，Value2 是包含实际操作列表的那个。嗯，Value2，如果我看看这个，它在做什么……好的，这是一个代码块，所以……
uh we need to get rid of our list of operations that value two takes as a left argument and so now we're just calling value on our list of numbers and I'm curious to see what happens if we go to bqn code aoc and let me hide this so I can see what I'm typing and we go bqn test. Oh, except it's taking time because I've got part b uncommented. This shouldn't take this long to run or maybe it actually does take. So, actually, let's get rid of this. Okay. So, this supposedly, at least for the mini input it might pass by accident because because
我们需要去掉 Value2 作为左参数接收的操作列表，所以现在我们只是在数字列表上调用 Value。我很好奇如果我们运行 BQN 代码 aoc 会发生什么，让我隐藏这个以便看到我输入的内容，然后运行 bqn test。哦，它在花时间，因为我取消了 Part B 的注释。运行不应该花这么长时间，或者也许确实需要。好吧，让我们去掉这个。好的，所以这至少对于小规模输入可能偶然通过，因为……
for the mini input the ones that work might just be simple additions or something else um there's only two that work in in the sample first and last and I'm not sure there might be ways to evaluate those. So the first one is trivial, like 10 times 19 is 190. There's only two terms. So I actually do recall it saying that it comments on the evaluation left to right. And not according to precedence. So the question is did i i think this is where the bug is not so i have with the single glyph reversed my numbers and made the tail
对于小规模输入，那些能通过的可能只是简单的加法或其他什么。样本中只有两个是有效的，第一个和最后一个，我不确定是否有其他方法来计算它们。所以第一个很简单，比如 10 乘以 19 等于 190。只有两项。我确实记得它提到过从左到右的求值。而不是根据优先级。所以问题是，我认为这就是 Bug 所在，我用单个字形反转了我的数字并使尾部……
backwards there was still a part in your video where you go from and the video shows this is going to be annoying i can i can bring it up and scroll it online um we're doing a deep dive so i mean there's a point in your video where you show here's the um here's the strings to be evaluated and the next beat is you showing the evaluations of them uh i think it's maybe another minute or so oh yeah so i am live coding it and technically i think you're correct then so in my video there might be a bug because i'm actually skipping the parsing code and i've just copy and pasted a single example and then definitely what you so that is you were paying super close attention uh i'm surprised
反转了。你的视频中确实有一部分，视频显示这会很烦人，我可以调出来在线滚动查看。我们正在深入研究，所以你的视频中有一个点，你展示了“这是要计算的字符串”，下一拍你展示了它们的求值结果。我想大概还有一分钟左右。哦，是的，我正在进行实时编码，从技术上讲你是对的，Ben。所以我的视频里可能有一个 Bug，因为我跳过了解析代码，只是复制粘贴了一个单一的例子。所以你确实是在非常仔细地观看，我很惊讶。
well i'm not surprised no one else caught that because that's such a narrow thing to catch but yes on the the video version i'm just doing it in bqm pad which is just a web editor and i i just assign to a single local variable called line uh input and skip all the parsing and therefore the solution that i've coded up misses the fact that you've actually need to reverse the tail portion of your line and ben clearly was uh paying attention to that and noticed that yeah so just after this but yeah you form the matrices and then you uh rotate uh transpose unravel them and then yeah so here we've got the expressions list now if we look at for example the third one six plus eight times six plus 15 evaluated strictly left to right it's's going to be 6 plus 8, 14, times 6, 84, plus 15, 99.
好吧，我不惊讶没人发现，因为那是一个非常细微的点。但确实，在视频版本中，我只是在 BQN Pad（一个网页编辑器）中操作，我只是把输入赋值给一个叫 line 的局部变量，跳过了所有的解析。因此，我编写的解决方案忽略了你需要反转行尾部分的事实。Ben 显然是在仔细观察并注意到了这一点。是的，就在这之后，你形成了矩阵，然后你旋转、转置、展开它们。然后，是的，这里我们有了表达式列表。现在如果我们看第三个，6 加 8 乘以 6 加 15，严格从左到右求值，应该是 6 加 8 等于 14，乘以 6 等于 84，加 15 等于 99。
Is that right? Or 84. 6, 14s are 84, right? Yeah, 7, 12s. Plus 15, 99. So the third number should be 99 when evaluated. But in fact, it comes out to 174 and 174 is 15 plus 6 21 times 8 168 plus 674 yeah and what's funny even while you were working through that math i was
对吗？或者 84。6 个 14 是 84，对吧？是的，7 个 12。加 15 等于 99。所以第三个数字求值后应该是 99。但实际上，结果是 174。而 174 是 15 加 6 等于 21，乘以 8 等于 168，加 6 等于 174。是的，有趣的是，即使在你计算数学的时候，我……
evaluating it right and i was like what is he doing six plus eight four and i lost you for a sec because i was like it's 21 and i was like was like, oh, right. The point being is that I'm evaluating a BQN expression, not a math expression. Well, it's not even math. It's left to right. It's technically small talk because if we're using ped mass, you do the eight times six first. Yeah. Yeah. But it's left to right versus right to left.
也在计算，我在想：“他在做什么？6 加 8 等于 4？”我有一秒钟没跟上，因为我在想：“是 21。”然后我想：“哦，对了。”重点是我在计算一个 BQN 表达式，而不是数学表达式。好吧，这甚至不是数学。它是从左到右的。从技术上讲，这是 Smalltalk 风格，因为如果我们使用 PEMDAS（运算优先级），你会先做 8 乘以 6。是的，是的。但这是从左到右与从右向左的区别。
Yeah. So, you are correct. There is a bug not in my… There's a bug in the video. Yeah. Clearly, you got the right answer because you you must have got the right answer to part one or you wouldn't have been doing yeah yeah exactly yeah and it skips to vs code like 30 seconds later where the parsing happens and silently there is a a both a
是的。所以你是对的。Bug 不在我的……视频里有一个 Bug。是的。显然你得到了正确答案，因为你一定得到了第一部分的正确答案，否则你不会做……是的，是的，完全正确。然后 30 秒后跳到了 VS Code，解析发生了，静默地有一个……
rotate and a reverse glyph because they are the same thing but in this case it's the it's the reverse glyph have you and how many so you said you've solved a couple problems i've solved like one two three seven and eleven that's all i've done this year okay i'm kind of resting on my laurels the first i've i've solved one complete year back when it was and i'm even on the leader board like 98 i I think, finally. In 2015, when almost no one was doing it and it was brand new, I did all the puzzles that year because I happened to have free time. Although at about day 15, so in the early, my leaderboard stacking, not that I really go in for competitive coding or fast coding,
旋转和一个反转字形，因为它们是同一个东西，但在这种情况下是反转字形。你解决了几个问题？我今年只做了 1、2、3、7 和 11。这就是我做的全部。好吧，我有点在吃老本。我曾经在某一年完整地解决过，我甚至在排行榜上排第 98 名，我想。在 2015 年，当时几乎没人做，而且它是全新的，我那年做了所有的谜题，因为我正好有空。虽然在大约第 15 天，所以早期我的排行榜排名……并不是说我真的热衷于竞技编程或快速编程……
but I was using the technique of you know do the puzzle by whichever is the best way to do it i think one of them was literally just it was like find the matching paren and it was like okay well i'll just open up this file do forward s expression do and find where the point is that's the answer so it was like do that in your editor um but yeah i think after on on one of the teen days 14 15 16 i i went from california to england and so suddenly i was going from puzzles at nine o'clock in the evening to puzzles at 5 a.m um which was the reason why my my my leaderboard really tailed off after that yeah that's a bit rough i yeah i'm jealous of the folks on the pacific coast it's a a much nicer time maybe not in the first couple
但我当时使用的技巧是：用最好的方式解决谜题。我想其中一个简直就是“找到匹配的括号”，我就想：“好吧，我只要打开这个文件，做前向 S 表达式查找，找到光标在哪里，那就是答案。”所以就像在编辑器里那样做。但是的，我想在十几号的那几天，14、15、16，我从加州飞往英国，所以突然间我从晚上 9 点做谜题变成了凌晨 5 点做谜题，这就是为什么我的排行榜排名在那之后大幅下滑的原因。是的，那确实有点难受。我嫉妒西海岸的人，时间好多了。也许不是在最初的几天……
days i think i'd solved them in less than 10 minutes. And actually, the servers were down. Oh, wow. On the opening night, I couldn't get access to the problem for, I think, three minutes. And it was, I can't remember what the error that I got was. But the last couple nights have been totally fine. But yeah, I think I solved it at the 10-minute mark. But it had been like three or four minutes before I got to the problem. But yeah, at 9 p.m., once the problems take like an hour ish to do doing that until 1 a.m in the morning yeah if you're doing that in
我想我在不到 10 分钟内就解决了它们。实际上，服务器宕机了。哦，哇。在开幕之夜，我大概有三分钟无法访问问题。我不记得我收到的错误是什么了。但最近几个晚上完全没问题。但是的，我想我在 10 分钟时解决了它。但在我进入问题之前已经过了三四分钟。但确实，在晚上 9 点，一旦问题需要一个小时左右才能完成，做到凌晨 1 点……是的，如果你在……
the small hours that's tough at some point probably you're like you know i just need to go to bed because it's not working out if i like continuing is not actually getting me any closer to solving it yeah and it's interesting i've never actually done a full year i'm not sure if i'll do all 25 but i'm at 28 stars 14 days so far and i'm almost all of these are just like grid-based path searching there hasn't been a ton of like algorithmic um which to be honest i'm not complaining because bqn it's brilliant like as soon as you have x y coordinates you can do like point addition by just you add you know oh i need to do a hundred moves and it's like well i i can just literally generate an iota sequence and then add my points to that and it works fine but uh i thought i
凌晨做这些，那很艰难。在某个时候，你可能会想：“我需要去睡觉了，因为如果我继续做下去，实际上并不能让我更接近解决它。”是的，这很有趣，我从来没有真正完成过完整的一年。我不确定我是否会做完所有 25 天，但我目前有 28 颗星，做了 14 天。几乎所有这些都是基于网格的路径搜索，没有太多的算法……说实话，我并不抱怨，因为 BQN 太棒了。一旦你有 X、Y 坐标，你就可以做点加法，比如：“哦，我需要做 100 次移动。”这就像：“好吧，我可以字面上生成一个 iota 序列，然后把我的点加到上面，它工作得很好。”但我想……
thought in years past it gets more tricky but maybe it's now that I just have parsing functions. And as soon as you can parse things. Yeah. Once you have the function to parse the input. Yeah. It gets rid of honestly, like 40% of the work sometimes. Yeah. I think last year,
我想往年这会更棘手，但也许是因为我现在有了解析函数。一旦你能解析事物……是的，一旦你有了解析输入的函数。是的，它消除了有时 40% 的工作量。是的，我想去年……
one of my colleagues, I think it was Michael who said like he was doing it. And then around about day 10, he got sidetracked by building like a pause, a combination library to deal with AOC. Completely reasonable. Anyways, we will leave links for everything we mentioned in the show notes. I would encourage folks, even if you only solve a single day, it doesn't need to be BQN.
我的一位同事，我想是 Michael，他说他在做这个。然后在第 10 天左右，他被构建一个解析组合子库来处理 AOC 给耽误了。完全合理。无论如何，我们会在节目说明中留下我们提到的所有内容的链接。我鼓励大家，即使你只解决了一天，也不一定非要是 BQN。
Choose a language that's on Ben's list. He had a tweet about it and a blog post about it in a different paradigm. You know, whether that's... Oh, I think that tweet is now deleted. Oh, I mean, we said last comment or last topic or last thing a couple different times. You mentioned Blue Sky. Are you on Blue Sky now? In as much as I'm on any social network, I am on Blue Sky.
选择一个 Ben 列表上的语言。他发过关于它的推文和博客文章，关于不同的范式。你知道，无论是……哦，我想那条推文现在被删除了。哦，我的意思是，我们已经好几次提到“最后一个评论”或“最后一个话题”或“最后一件事”了。你提到了 Blue Sky。你现在在用 Blue Sky 吗？就我使用任何社交网络而言，我确实在用 Blue Sky。
I have zero posts, but I exist. I see. Cause now this is like three months after I joined Mastodon. It's like, and this is why I held off for so long. It's cause there's continues to be this proliferation. And, uh, I just, I don't need more. I just, I just need one. I don't want, I don't want any.
我发了零条帖子，但我存在。我明白了。因为这距离我加入 Mastodon 已经三个月了。这就是我推迟了这么久的原因，因为这种激增持续存在。而且，我不需要更多。我只需要一个。我不想要，我不想要任何一个。
And, uh. All right. But you're on Blue Sky. And are you off of Twitter now? Because you said it might be deleted or is it everything's gone? My Twitter account exists, so no one can impersonate me. But there's nothing there. And to be fair, I hadn't tweeted anything since 2020. You know, the pandemic was a good time to quit social media.
而且……好吧。但你在 Blue Sky 上。你现在离开 Twitter 了吗？因为你说它可能被删除了，还是说一切都没了？我的 Twitter 账号存在，所以没人能冒充我。但那里什么都没有。公平地说，我自 2020 年以来就没发过推文了。你知道，疫情是退出社交媒体的好时机。
Yeah. I'm trying to think. Well, so, some of your tweets live on in my talks because I've screenshotted them. But the ones that I've retweeted, that means they're gone now. But your favorite one, the one about, I mean, it still exists in idea land, right? Yeah. Well, you still have the blog post. The idea is learn. Yeah, it's exists in idea land, right? Yeah. Well, you still have the blog post. The idea is learn.
是的。我在想。好吧，你的一些推文在我的演讲中得以留存，因为我截了图。但我转发的那些，意味着它们现在没了。但你最喜欢的那条，关于……我的意思是，它仍然存在于“想法之地”，对吧？是的。好吧，你还有博客文章。想法是学习……是的，它存在于“想法之地”，对吧？是的。好吧，你还有博客文章。想法是学习。
Yeah, I still have the blog post. Although the blog, you know, I blog recently, actually. I blog about once or twice a year these days. Yeah. And the idea is learn languages that will increase the paradigms, increase your toolkit. So, you know, C++ java and rust and python they're all at some level the same language um as distinct from apl bqn that's entirely different family you know uh haskell lisp different family small talk prologue prologue yeah there's uh a bunch of different ones and
是的，我还有那篇博客文章。虽然博客，你知道，我最近确实写了博客。这些天我一年大概写一两次。想法是学习那些能增加范式、增加工具包的语言。所以，你知道，C++、Java、Rust 和 Python，它们在某种程度上是同一种语言。与 APL、BQN 不同，那是完全不同的家族。你知道，Haskell、Lisp 是不同的家族，Smalltalk、Prolog……Prolog，是的，有很多不同的语言，而且……
you'll know you'll know when you stumble into a new one because yeah because everything will be really difficult and you're wondering how to do things and how on earth do these people get anything done in this language it's not like how i expect but also it can be freeing you know whenever i'm in a language where i feel like i'm an expert in i am always oh you know i can never just do something you know the wrong way just to get things done because people are watching but then you come to a new paradigm it's like well i don't know what i'm doing people can't judge me you know i i yeah right at the top of my t-shirt says i don't know what i'm doing here so uh every anything goes and uh yeah absolutely and with fm code like we said any route to a solution counts there's no there's no cheating there's no gatekeeping here if you can solve it in whatever
当你偶然发现一门新语言时，你会知道的，因为一切都会非常困难，你会想：“怎么做这些事？这些人到底是怎么用这门语言完成工作的？”它不像我预期的那样。但它也可以是自由的。你知道，每当我处于一门我感觉自己是专家的语言中时，我总是……你知道，我永远不能只是用“错误的方式”来完成事情，因为有人在看。但当你来到一个新的范式时，就像是：“好吧，我不知道我在做什么，人们无法评判我。”你知道，我……是的，我的 T 恤上写着“我不知道我在这里做什么”。所以，一切皆有可能。而且，是的，绝对是这样。对于 FM 代码，就像我们说的，任何通往解决方案的路径都算数。没有作弊，没有门槛。如果你能用任何……
language great if you can't solve it look up a solution and learn from it yeah still works they only ask for the answer not for the code code. Alrighty. Well, I guess we'll say happy holidays to both you and the listeners. Yeah, thanks. Well, at this point, I'm not sure at what point the happy holidays portion will actually come out. So, maybe I'll have to cut this into a sooner episode. We've recorded at least three three if not four episodes here and uh so we'll be saying happy holidays in second week of january this was supposed to this was supposed to be an hour and it's gone almost twice as long as that because i budgeted more than an hour i have to say
语言解决它，那就太棒了。如果你解决不了，查一下解决方案并从中学习。是的，仍然有效。他们只要求答案，不要求代码。好吧。那么，我想我们要祝你和听众节日快乐。是的，谢谢。好吧，在这一点上，我不确定节日快乐的部分会在什么时候发布。所以，也许我得把它剪辑到更早的一期节目里。我们在这里录制了至少三期，如果不是四期的话。所以我们会在一月份的第二周说节日快乐。这本来应该是一个小时的，结果几乎是两倍长，因为我预算的时间超过了一个小时，我必须说……
because you know we get together we only talk to each other once a month or so and we always have interesting things to talk about yeah yeah especially if you're going to ask questions that are algorithmic plus apl plus bqn central then yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna we're gonna lose track of time you add haskell in there c++ Anyways, I might try to insert this little happy holidays. Yeah, happy holidays. And if not, then maybe it's happy new year to the listener as well. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
因为你知道，我们聚在一起，一个月左右才聊一次，我们总是有有趣的话题可以聊。是的，是的，特别是如果你要问那些算法加 APL 加 BQN 核心的问题，那么是的，我们会失去时间感。你再加上 Haskell、C++……无论如何，我可能会尝试插入这个小小的节日快乐。是的，节日快乐。如果不行，那么也许也祝听众新年快乐。请务必在你的播客应用中或在 ADSP the podcast.com 查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论的链接……
where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号（anti-brace）。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。